hallo mein name ist lud herzlich
willkommen leuten wie direkte
wahrscheinlich den youtube trend
mitbekommen dass irgendwie cristian
ronaldo und lionel messi und emma und
andere stars aus dem ausland auf
deutsche videos reagiert das ist jetzt
auch mit mir passiert wenn ich's
internet gestöbert und habe ein video
gefunden und justin bieber herrscht auf
das echteste schwinke video von mir
reagiert haben sind sagen wir von
anderen rummler schauen wir uns doch
direkt mal an
von jacques rocca lima moment raste das
ist keine scheiße okay ich habe diese
glossybox zugesendet bekommen und haben
wir gedacht hey dabei ich darüber ein
video und schminke mich und schnell das
ganze co medial mit ihr an das gibt es
dieses wort definitiv nein aber wir
schauen immer weiter bei ducati empfang
geht damit noch schöner wird herzchen
ilya das ist mein manager bei 471 toyota
klima kalima media es ist übrigens kein
toller kessel voller dollar den ion
monat geld man ihn an die million mal
hinein schafften es war keine rolle
place wenn es war wirklich ich habe die
box zugesendet bekommen und die mal was
damit irgendwas schminktisch und
wir haben tatsächlich in dieser box noch
eine also wir haben jetzt mal vermeiden
wie sie gut scheint aber dass alle
markteilnehmer ist unser puffer baguette
gp paar tapas thema aber hey da muss ich
selber wirklich zugeben dass ich mich
auf frage wie sich zwei mal so eine
blöde heimweg gemacht hat also ich habe
mich jetzt auf jeden fall diese sechs
produkte toyota kamasutra frische rom
palermo boateng grossmüller tschabahar
ja mama justin wir jetzt mal ein
bisschen fortune no idea how to
schwindender poker kaliber kippte ihn
glazer
du weißt nicht kann eigentlich ein altes
lied englischen ort in dem video
englisch baguette und es kämpfe dann zu
entfernen nimmt man einfach die dinge
zwischen tanja puta madre portieren com
coca cola baby bhutan orientieren
training dafür wer brüder den reich
ecofit bewährten noch nach ghana von
schloss ein bisschen jetzt so gemein zu
mir get all your kleeblatts moko
grabstein okay das war gemein justin
also dass seine tote oma erstmal rest in
peace dass du mir sagst ist eine tote
uroma sich besser schminken kann als ich
boutique queen schlechthin
das trifft mich schon aber wir schauen
straight video mal weiter calamari conti
celine unter reparatur des klimacamps
trikots t kanal aus was zweifel
baguette aber ich wünsche mir jetzt
einfach mal in die hände haben definitiv
zu viel genommen
piquet messi ronaldo wo soll das
hinführen mühlacker von alhambra
barclays bkn taschentücher box vor
schluss gegen die youtuber pr oder die
look weiter matrikon verbot das ist
gemein aber jetzt endet auch schon das
rack video das war sie von dem video
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch irgendwie gefallen yamada erster
malaga habe habe die lamer kendrick
justin ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen traurig dachte wirklich wir
werden so herzens brüder und du feiert
meine videos und so aber diese reaktion
kann das fand ich das war sie auch schon
von dem video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich habe
einmal gedacht das zdf youtube trend ist
jemand irgendwas nimmt und die reagieren
darauf dass es deswegen die analysten
keine arbeit ist das gefallen hat nicht
das sie jetzt ja auch ein bisschen dran
weil mit green screen und der ganzen
vorbereitung ganze sache und ich musste
mir die ganze sprach er auch erst mal
beibringen lassen auf jeden fall leicht
habe ich das ganze noch mal machen soll
vielleicht mit kylie jenner oder was
weiß ich lebe noch in irgendeiner
anderen promis schreibt man in die
kommentare reagiert wenn ihr jetzt noch
dran seid hier findet ihr einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf hier könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren schillig weil
ich eigentlich jeden tag beschissene
gequirlte scheiße hochladen und hier
findet ihr das video eingeblendet auf
das casting gerade reagiert hat nämlich
dass ich teste schminke video könnt ihr
auf jeden fall mehr ausschenken ist
eigentlich auch total blöd